[Musique]
paul détourner ni l'arrêter et
démolition s'est échappé ou absolument
que l'on fait
ouais
m
il faut et c'est cet engin avant d'une
annexe le port de charge de l'éloigner
des titres
[Musique]
merci jeune épouse est bien gentil
vous
tu t'es laver les mains avec du savon
tu les a bien séché je voulais donc là
dedans c'est moi sinon est ce qu il est
prévu qu'on en parle un jour croix du
sujet tabou évidemment quels sujets
tabous de nouveau travail de maman il
est temps
grand temps de réparer nos erreurs aidez
nous à faire sortir de l'ombre tous les
supers nous
vont changer l'opinion des gens sur les
super-héros et pour cela élastique girl
est notre meilleur atout meilleur que
moi
[Musique]
or marc cherry maman pour des enfants
pas quand même
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire papa
le premier condo utilisent cette méthode
je connais pas cette méthode est
pourquoi ils changent les maths les
maths c'est les maths mais mars est des
marques tout comme en séries
comment des enfants très bien j'espère
c'est soit la petite de deux sens et
jacquet est très en forme c'est quoi ça
au ketchup aussi bloqué wahou
d'accord ça c'est flippant c'est
complètement fou pour aider ma famille
et je dois l'a quitté il pour faire
régner la loi la transgresser le pour
nos enfants pour qu'ils puissent avoir
le choix
[Musique]
combustion imminent qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire y'a le feu
le nautiz l'enterrons ce programme afin
devant des ivoiriens message enfile son
costume ça va chauffer j'arrive je me
dépêche
[Musique]